SCP-682 Vs SCP-393.
So many of the Foundation’s plans to kill
SCP-682 have failed, but maybe that’s just
because they never wrote it down in SCP-393,
this singularly unique day planner.
SCP-393 is a day planner that bonds to a nearby
subject, and when they write their plans into
it, they will soon develop a complete memory
of having achieved those plans.
Perhaps this could be used to figure out how
to kill 682.
A D-Class was given the planner, and asked
to write “Going to somehow defeat SCP-682
today.”
The D-Class was later found comatose with
a horrified expression on their face, and
died shortly after.
A defeated note from a young research assistant
on the test file reads, “It was worth a
shot…”